after meeting with the elves and some of  the other train conductors  and as a choir from the las vegas  academy wrapped up their holiday carols  [Music]  it was time to fire up the polar express  engine at the cleverly disguised  cimarron rose community center's sports  courts on ann road dear durango  the elves danced  hot chocolate was served  [Music]  then  [Music]  the big man showed up  and the kids snapped pictures with him  before we all went home  a simple night about an hour so long but  the kids had a ball and special thanks  to erin clark from the cimarron rose  community center for inviting me  the tip of the conductors had also to  the small but mighty little engine that  could staff that work with energy  enthusiasm and camaraderie to bring joy  to hundreds of families with little kids  yeah